if you're struggling with a task you
would say that self-compassion is an
effective strategy and that's basically
recognizing that to struggle with things
is part of a learning process it's part
of Being Human not getting it right on
the first time you know and that's often
people we they start things and then
they realize oh it's not going the way I
planned right um I'm and that's that's
when they can abandon it because they've
made a mistake and the perfectionism
kicks in and everything that's when you
need to be self-compassionate um so
self-compassion kicks in when we're
struggling with our own personal
failings shortcomings difficult thoughts
about ourselves and the task Etc and
basically it's just being kind rather
than critical rather than saying what's
wrong with me why can't I get this right
and recognizing that this is something
everybody does and people tend to be
critical but also they all struggle and
that's just part of Being
Human